bodies of eleven Ukrainians killed on
board a passenger plane which Iran said
it has mistakenly shot down have been
repatriated they've received a military
god of honor in Kiev in a ceremony
attended by President Vladimir szalinski
authorities in Iran say they're
analyzing the flight recorders from the
Ukrainian Airlines an airliner and have
no current plans to send the black boxes
overseas Iran is under pressure to
compensate the families of the 176
victims let speak foreign correspondents
in Tehran dosage ybarra door sir first
what's the latest in the investigation
and Iranian authorities had said they
were sending the black box recorders of
the plane to Ukraine what's changed well
we know that over the past 24 hours
there's some confusion about whether or
not the authorities here would send the
two black boxes that they retrieved from
the crash site near Imam Khomeini
Airport but according to the head of the
investigations team of the Civil
Aviation Authority in Iran the Iranians
have no plans to send either of the
black boxes to be analyzed either in
Ukraine or any other Western country for
that matter for the first evil future
that's what we know so far we do know
that the 150 bodies out of the hundred
and seventy-six victims have been
identified and have been given back to
the loved ones at the eleven that we
know have been sent back to Ukraine is
just part of the ones that they are
given back the bodies to the country
that they're supposed to go back to the
authorities here say that they don't
plan on giving this black boxes to any
other country for the time being because
they're still analyzing they're trying
to retrieve the data that is on those
boxes to try and piece together what
happened in that the last moments of the
flights before it was shut down by
Iranian officials this is something that
has been ongoing they also have had
officials from the Ukraine Germany and
France and Canada who have come to Iran
to help in the investigation so we are
waiting to find out more about the first
initial reports that will come from this
investigation but for the time being we
know that
black boxes will remain in Iran and
what's been happening on the diplomatic
front store sir well there was a lot of
criticism initially not only by the
international community but also by
Iranians inside the country because
officials here denied any involvement in
this plane being shot down they said
that it was impossible and for days they
denied it happening and then in the
sudden turn of events we saw that the
Revolutionary Guard admitted that it had
mistakenly shot down the plane since
then there's been a lot of diplomatic
efforts trying to salvage the faith that
people would have in the authorities
here and we've even heard from the
Supreme Leader delivering a rare Friday
sermon this past Friday in Tehran
Ayatollah Ali Khamenei who said that
indeed this was a bitter accident and
it's broken the hearts of the nation but
that the Western powers are seeking this
opportunity to question Iran's
Revolutionary Guard and the commitment
the Iranian public has in the Islamic
establishment so he warned that not to
let the diplomacy that is ongoing to
question the fundamentals of this
country at the same time the Foreign
Minister Mohammad Javad Zarif has been
meeting with a Canadian foreign minister
because a number of the victims had dual
nationalities they were Canadian
Iranians and the Canadian government has
had a big part in all of this as well he
met with the Canadian foreign minister
in Oman on Saturday and they continue to
have this dialogue to try and resolve
the investigate the ongoing
investigation and trying to further
cooperation between all sides and trying
to figure out what actually happened and
put this incident behind them but
there's a lot more questions than
answers at the moment and the government
is certainly trying its best to not let
this incident destroy Iran's diplomatic
relations dosage Avari in Tehran thank
you